it's the first visit of its kind in more
than 30 years in Sudan's conflict-ridden
history after fighting the Sudanese
government for more than eight years
leader of the rebel movement to dance
people liberation movement north abdul
aziz and haloo welcomed the country's
prime minister abdullah ham doke to a
territory he seized in the war
this is kao de in the Nuba Mountains in
South Kordofan state we welcomed the
Prime Minister and his delegation here
to Couder as a sign of peace the
December 2018 revolution that overthrew
the previous government and brought this
government is not yet over and until
there is peace
the revolution continues the war in
south kordofan started in June 2011
after the SPLM North accused Sudan's
government of marginalization and
impeding democracy according to a deal
signed between the government and then
Southern Sudan in 2005 known as the
comprehensive peace agreement nuba
mountains was supposed to have the
chance to decide whether it wanted to be
part of Sudan or join South Sudan 15
years since the signing of the
comprehensive peace agreement South
Kordofan is still at a political impasse
parts of the state is controlled by the
Sudanese government and parts by the
SPLM north under Abdul Aziz in helu
while the two sides are not their
differences to end nine years of war
here in rebel-held Couder the years of
fighting has displaced hundreds of
thousands and created a humanitarian
crisis more than a dozen rounds of peace
talks failed to end the conflicts in the
past but since Sudan's transitional
government was sworn in in August after
months of protests that eventually led
to the overthrow of longtime President
Omar al-bashir in April it has been
pushing for a new comprehensive peace
deal we will be able to keep this
content together provided that we create
a system that will allow just democratic
Sudan
up all our diversity our respect for
each other and built on citizenship we
are confident we reach that over 70,000
people have been displaced to camps in
South Sudan as those who remained inside
face the horrors of the world Irina
Elena we face daily bombardments we lost
our home we lost our children and many
relatives in the war and we've suffered
a lot eight organizations say the visit
of the prime minister while it can be
described as historic needs to be
followed up with more actions to ease
the impact of the war I mean it's not
just the Nuba Mountains area it's not
just the blue dallas all across Sudan we
want to make sure we have the access the
support we need from all the different
parties and factions since so far we've
been getting it from everyone and that
is really quite remarkable many here say
they never thought a day would come when
a rebel-held territory would open its
doors to a government official now
they're waiting to see how committed is
the months-old government in ending the
war for good so that the lives destroyed
by it can be rebuilt Heba Morgan al
Jazeera todo South Kordofan